here we are children come and get your
lollipops
i have lots of lovely goodies for you
grab some turkish delight and cherry
blossom tea
because we have the latest episode of
the falcon in the winter soldier
unfortunately no zemo dancing
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into episode 4 titled the whole
world is watching
analyzing its ending easter eggs and
hidden details
so make sure to smash that like and
subscribe button because
here we go well at least this episode
isn't starting with a commercial
the global repatriation council knows
that for many
it wasn't that easy we're in wakanda six
years ago to be exact with io reciting
the words used to trigger the winter
soldier
we saw io the second in command of the
dora melange at the end of episode 3.
this is all part of a test to see if
bucky can free himself of his winter
soldier programming which it seems he's
been able to overcome
io refers to the programming removal
like taking off
rotten fur an apt analogy since he's
referred to as the white wolf
he experiences flashbacks of his time as
the winter soldier including the
assassination of maria stark
tony stark's mother notice the
difference in cobblestones here showing
how bucky and io are on two different
sides ayo wants revenge for zemo's
killing of king t'chaka which sparked
the events of civil war she at least
gives bucky and sam eight hours before
warning him that they'll be coming for
zema
he gives her back her komoyo beats which
if you haven't watched my episode 3
breakdown
i talk about their significance back at
their safe house which
really isn't that safe since it seems
everyone seems to pop up here at some
point
bucky explains the situation they need
to find carly asap to track down the
serum before the wakandans come looking
for zemo notice here these stained glass
windows covered in red white and blue
stars a nod to captain america and also
to the red star on the winter soldier's
arm
word has gotten out about carly's attack
on the grc supply depot which left 11
injured and three dead well zemo argues
the philosophy of the super soldier
serum stating anyone who wants it is a
supremacist and stating that
steve rogers is the only super soldier
who was never corrupted by the serum's
power
and we'll see how that power corrupts
our good friend john walker
later in the episode at the grc refugee
camp zemo sings baba black sheep which
has a very dark origin
it's a reference to the 13th century
wool tax in which farmers had to pay
two-thirds of their earnings to the king
and church the original version had
nothing left for the little
shepherd boy who lives down the lane
just like these children
have nothing bribing with turkish
delight the same treat the witch in the
line the witch and the wardrobe used to
bribe the young boy edmund with
zemo is able to find where donya
madani's memorial will be held
she being the key to locating carly
morgenthau of course zemo withholds this
info for as long as he can from sam and
bucky fearing that as soon as he tells
them he'll no longer be of use to them
and have to be turned back to
authorities sam enlists the help of
sharon carter who he met last episode
she just so happens to have some spare
satellites around to track john walker
and carly
notice how she's walking down this
street with tons of armed guards around
her these two clues along with
several others in my last video hint
that she is the power broker
carly and nico have stored seven vials
of super soldier serum under the grave
of nico's grandfather lucas who was a
world war ii resistance fighter it's
ironic that nico talks about looking up
to captain america as a kid and in this
episode
literally dies while looking up to him
nico sees carly as a new captain america
one who understands the pain
he and others like him have gone through
a hero who isn't afraid to get their
hands dirty
in episode 1 sam even says the world
needs a new type of hero
we need new heroes
one suited for the times we're in carly
concludes saying the shield should be
destroyed as it's a reminder of a bygone
era
john and lamar have tracked down sam and
bucky who are with the fugitive zemo
they want to bring zemo in but he's the
only one who knows where donya's funeral
is being held sam wants to go in alone
thinking that carly in this vulnerable
state of losing a loved one will be more
willing to talk and for the most
part he is right at its core sam and
carly are fighting for the same thing
she even says the people i'm fighting
are trying to take your home
some a reference to the bank trying to
take his and his sister's fishing boat
but the ways the two of them go about
bringing
justice are wildly different carly will
do whatever it takes even killing the
innocent while sam won't stoop to that
level
and just as sam starts to earn carly's
trust the new cap has to stroll in
and screw everything up zemo manages to
escape from his handcuffs and also
somehow acquire a gun
a gun which he'll later use to shoot
carly this seems to be a common
occurrence with him
back in episode 2 we saw how matthias
was shot in the stomach by cat but later
is somehow healed this seems to be the
case with carly in this episode the
serum having advanced
regenerative qualities in episode 3 we
learned from nagel the creator of the
serum that 20 vials were made
here at the cemetery we see seven of
them and here on the ground we see eight
plus there were the vials carly and her
team took this is all to say that when
zemo smashes the files the show hints
that there is only one left and that one
captain america will use on himself
however the show playing fast and loose
with these numbers you never
know when another one could be at play
carly gets a text from the power broker
funny it's always a text
and never a call whoever is on the other
end is wanting his or her identity
hidden with the power broker sam and
bucky and cal and lamar on her tail she
decides to separate them
and pick off captain america with their
eight hours up
io and two of her dora melanche nombel
and yama comfort zemo cap and lamar
arrive and a fight ensues with zemo
making an el chapo escape a nod to how
mexican drug lord
el chapo guzman escaped his prison via
hidden passageway under his cell's
washroom bucky is
literally disarmed something he didn't
know could happen which leads me to
believe this might happen again in the
future
cap however gets the worst of it getting
his ass beaten so hard he says
thank you sir i have another oh not that
one they weren't even super soldier
and this has all been part of how the
writers have been building up his
character so he'd get to the point where
we'd believe he'd take this super
soldier serum
this started all the way back in episode
2 when he talks about the pressure of
being the new cap
and living up to expectations everybody
in the world expects me to be
something and i don't want to fail them
in a one-on-one with his bff cap asked
lamar if he had the chance would he take
the serum lamar responds by saying
think of the amount of lives they could
have saved in afghanistan if they had it
between now and the time we see cap bend
a steel pipe it's implied he has taken
the serum and we'll later see him
tweaking out a possible side effect of
this
carly calls sarah and basically
threatens to kill her and her kids
unless she sets up a meeting between her
and sam
there's also a deep conversation about
how this new captain america means
nothing to her my world doesn't matter
to america so
why should i care about its mascot her
world meaning that of a black woman in
america
falcon in the winter soldier hasn't
shied away from politics
episode 2 delved into isaiah bradley and
its nod to the tuskegee experiments
this is also yet another hint that sam
her brother will
end up taking the shield sam meets up
with carly and to his surprise
she asks him to join her they both want
the same thing they just have
different ways of going about it sharon
warns sam that kappas found them out and
a fight ensues with carly killing lamar
before making a run for it this is the
last straw for jon who tracks down nico
one of the flag smashers and
kills him in cold blood the title of
this episode the whole world is watching
has
two meanings here not only is the whole
world watching as the public records
this violent act but the phrase itself
started as an anti-vietnam
war slogan and has since been picked up
by movements like black lives matter the
shield is
literally covered in blood a metaphor
for carly's view of it being a symbol of
oppression but as sam stated in episode
1
symbols
are nothing without the women and men
that give them meaning this new cap has
made the shield a symbol of
injustice whereas the old cap one of
courage justice and hope spoilers for
those who haven't seen the promotional
material but we see jon here looking as
though he's lamenting what has just
happened
and we see bucky and sam back in
louisiana with the shield
it's not certain yet if this new captain
america is relieved of his duty and it
goes to sam
or if sam forcibly takes it back from
him after watching this murder whatever
happens next we'll just have to wait
until next week
to find out thanks for watching everyone
if you liked the video be sure to give
it a like
subscribe and share for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much